[Music]
you
[Music]
and you about the existence of comedians
in Middle School
French and Russian settlement out of
Russia far behind the Arctic Circle
I never thought of visiting these
because I knew that a ghost town
so nobody this year and the fact is to
find I have no idea how to get here
I found an announcement the website of
Russian Geographical Society about this
position right behind the most
experienced guy ever I've been working
as a guide in many many regions of the
world for more than 10 years and I got
employed I suspect that I was the only
candidate to apply my name is Alexander
romanovski everybody knows me as Sasha
from pyramid
[Music]
the Volusia number biogenic the Soviet
period of time it was a very prestigious
place to work here me then supplied
northern regions of the Soviet Union
with cold I heard an opinion that pure
Meighan is the only place in the world
where communism was actually built
I happened to talk to the people who
live and work here in 1970 and in 1980s
and they consider the years they spent
in German to be the best years of their
life but when the Soviet Union collapsed
unquestioned superior middens added
withering and people started moving out
of here
in 1998 the decision was made to close
down the mine and to send all the people
back to the mainland
I came here in 2012 if you are here
currently we have six people could live
here more or less permanently we need to
be friendly peaceful and we need to
treat each other with respect
that's why political talks are strictly
forbidden here if they were not
forbidden many if no idea what would
happen two of us are from Western
Ukraine to Russia from Donetsk to Lazar
Russian so it's better to keep silence
and will it
ever then to make a call to my office in
Barnesville it is situated about 100
kilometres to the south from here they
inform me about whom and when should I
expect
sometimes helicopter delivers us
correspondent maybe it's the most
precious thing here because you know
intermittent we still use this
old-fashioned manner of communicating
with friends and relatives we write
letters we send letters and we receive
letters a very slow process but
nevertheless very nice okay so everybody
yeah let's go
last autumn I proposed to use these
bricks to build a great wall around
pyramidan to protect us from polar bears
and they are still thinking about it
nah I'm joking of course
now because last autumn in October we
had an accident here and a polar bear
broke in and it was scary physically now
it's funny to remember but that night we
were all pretty scared I was supposed to
be eaten first because I live on the
second floor and my others live on the
fourth floor well but I heard him moving
the furniture he broke in for the window
then he got to the bar to drink our beer
yes when he devours our not storage he
just took some - out of the fridge and
then he went out the same way he came in
well and we did not kill him we are very
proud of it I am NOT allowed to go
outside without my rifle this polar
bears are quite often to be noticed in
the area and sometimes they walk up and
down the street the last time I saw
polar bear it was last Wednesday I am
asking face-to-face at the pier and I
got scared
to be honest because it was a very
unexpected meeting suddenly he shows up
from behind the mountain of abstract
metal I had to shoot twice in the air of
course not into the bear to just scare
him away
when guiding I'm responsible for the
tourists and I'm responsible for their
life so I have my gun loaded and ready
to shoot
I like this place I'd like to make sure
and I obviously like my job for the
surprise for me to start loving with
occupation because I'm not a sociable
person I don't feel uncomfortable being
alone here in Canada and jassu Iranian
cuchara margarita margarita margarita
por favor margarita last a great area
entra in la oficina de Lola elders here
and del Carlos Sanchez
it's an obligatory condition we need to
obtain some special features of
characters who live here I got used to
it too much I think so for me routine
and ordinary thing to realize I am bar
behind the Arctic Circle maybe I am the
northernmost - head banger in the world
thank that is
is
[Music]
then thinking one-on-one time like
you're hot and boring right you like a
girl out here on the first time
everybody knows me
nothing teachers work and you just want
to fight me in before baby can be
[ __ ] Russian no I this idea no this
one
very
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
it's good
[Music]
[Music]
yes sorry
maybe one working for it is enough
you
[Music]
[Music]
you